[Music]
hi my name is Annie Onishi
Annie is a general surgeon at Columbia
University today we're gonna be breaking
down clips from movies and television
about the emergency room and the
operating room slapping the patient via
Biss roll the clip so rule number one of
CPR is never stop effective chest
compressions in order to slap or yell
words of encouragement at the patient's
yelling at a patient or cheering them on
has never brought them back to life
so here we have another example we tried
smelling salts caffeine injections ice
baths that's not really how we do in
real life
we have other mean methods to wake up a
patient who has some sort of
neurological problem we have a
proposition for you
including pressing on the nail beds as
hard as you possibly can or rubbing on
their sternum thank you appendectomy
spies like us and now the first incision
first of all you need two people and two
people only to remove a patient's
appendix I don't know why there's 25
people in that room second of all that
is the hairiest abdomen I've seen in a
really long time
not the succor surgeons have very severe
OCD and all hair needs to be removed
before we even think about operating if
a patient reacts like that to an
incision it means anesthesiologist isn't
doing his or her job this man is dead
and check out this gas now people who
are about to die do display something
called agonal breathing which is a very
characteristic pattern of respirations
but nothing like that something tells me
that these guys are not real doctors
[Music]
coats Rookie Blue in detail that's very
accurate is the first person who
responded to the code did a nice job of
removing all the excess furniture from
the room this is gonna make a lot of
extra room for personnel any equipment
that may be used to help save this
patient another very nice detail the
nurse calls for help before she even
begins chest compressions on the patient
it's always important to have backup in
a situation like this there a systole
this scene also uses some very official
sounding doctor words such as asystole
and v-fib or v-tach these are also real
conditions that would occur during a
cardiac arrest and their responses are
accurate yeah now if you check out the
code scene and drop dead diva somebody
in the room says prepare to intubate I
need a 12 French this is basically
nonsense talk it sounds medical but it's
not real at all another thing I
overheard someone say is given when the
fluids wide open that's pretty accurate
something someone may very well say in a
code and the amp is sort of an
unreliable way to communicate a dose of
epinephrine usually we talk in
milligrams run the fluids wide open
refers to physically opening up the
lines that the IV fluids are running in
so that the patient gets as much fluid
as possible as fast as possible charge
in the 360
all clear so here they charge the
defibrillator to 360 joules which is an
accurate dose of electricity in order to
get the heart kick-started into a rhythm
that works
we got a shockable rhythm 200 joules
back in Rookie Blue they charge to 200
joules
which is an outdated dose of electricity
and no longer thought to be effective
now in basketball they shock somebody
with 15,000 volts
machine only goes up to 360 so 15
thousands a little bit unreasonable you
know what you're doing what's it look
like an execution adrenaline to the
heart okay I think it's ready an
arrhythmia is when the heart is not
beating in a coordinated fashion for
certain arrhythmias a milligram of
epinephrine or adrenaline is exactly
what we would use to kickstart the heart
into what we would call perfusing rhythm
hurry up man hurry up here I'll tell you
what thank you you can give the shot I'm
what you're probably be doing chest
compressions as they're trying to sort
all this out thank you thank you for the
shot there's a whole lot of standing
around a whole lot of waiting around for
you all right time is myocardium people
it's got to be hard enough to get
through her breastplate into her heart
you also wouldn't really necessarily
have to go straight through the sternum
to access the heart you could very
easily access the heart through one of
the intercostal spaces which is the
space between two ribs all right and say
something something a little bit of a
stretch but it is plausible that
adrenaline straight to the heart would
help patient privacy hangover and cough
first of all if you're gonna check some
old sweaty do it's prostate please put
on two gloves come on what we have here
on our hands is a big big HIPAA
violation which is the law that protects
patients privacy interesting you would
never ever examine a patient in his
underwear in front of a couple of other
patients and you would never discuss
patient care in front of someone else no
big deal selfies in the or Grey's
Anatomy okay what is so mesmerizing that
you can't do your job those worms I
can't look away
[Music]
if you took photos of an anesthetized
patient without their explicit prior
written permission you could get in a
lot of trouble you could lose your
medical license even almost certainly
get fired no more while it may seem
far-fetched there is a parasitic
infection called strangle Louise this
one that does cause your test ins to get
completely blocked up by these worms and
a lot of times you do need an operation
to get them removed happy nightmares
removing a bullet mr. Beach we're losing
him I've gotta get in there now one of
the most frequent things I hear in an
operating room on TV or in the movies is
losing him I have never once heard that
in my real life ever once the point of
trauma surgery after a gunshot wound is
not necessarily to go get the bullet out
what you're really there to do is fix
the damage that's caused by the bullet
plenty of people walking around out
there with bullets that show up on
x-rays all the time so the patient seems
to be cured here by just the removal of
the bullet which I can guarantee you is
not what happens and again here we have
another example of a patient being
miraculously cured by just the removal
of a bullet check out Harold and Kumar
[Music]
genius in general somebody who's shot in
the chest is not cured by simply
removing the bullet that bullets usually
caused all kinds of damage inside that
needs to be fixed you guys did it no
I've never actually seen anybody cheer
when a bullet gets removed because
that's usually the least exciting part
of that operation and of course with
every bullet removal
there's the quintessential
thank you doesn't happen in real life
those buckets are actually plastic so
less impressive operating room galleries
Seinfeld
so just like in Grey's Anatomy
this fictional hospital also seems to
have a viewing gallery for people to
just sit around and watch operations
don't they have work to do Oh back in
the day before we had the internet or
textbooks operating galleries did
definitely exist they're depicted in a
number of famous paintings from the 20th
century but these days is just not a
thing talking she's sorry operating room
fashioned dead rares
[Music]
you'd think red scrubs were not very
realistic but it turns out they are
surgeons and people who work in the
operating room have to wear a specific
color of scrubs and at my hospital it's
red
once you've scrubbed in and your hands
are considered sterile you do need other
people's help to get you dressed
patient awareness during an operation
from the film so this is a young man
undergoing what looks to be an open
heart operation who is fully conscious
of the proceedings around him I'm
supposed to be asleep in general
patients don't really dream while
they're under anesthesia this phenomenon
is called intra operative awareness and
luckily it is exceedingly rare yeah in
this detail right here the patient's
eyelids are taped closed while they're
asleep very real it's to prevent corneal
abrasions sleeping like a baby for me
the most cringe-worthy aspect of this
clip is the hair removal from the
patients chest razors actually cause
very tiny abrasions in the skin which
lead to a higher risk of surgical site
infections we would never ever ever ever
ever use a razor we use electric
Clippers this is something I've never
actually seen film or TV get right
players may have changed but the game is
still the same things getting stuck in
patients butts from a whole lot of TV
shows no in real life this is very very
common whatever floats your boat man
I got musical farts I've seen a carrot
and eggplant all kinds of dildos of
different shapes sizes and electronic
capabilities a wineglass an axe can of
body spray shaving cream that's about it
emergency airway control the heat
[Music]
perform an emergency tracheotomy I'm
gonna need a glass of vodka so I really
admire Sandra Bullock's hutzpah here I
do think that she's really trying to
take this situation into her own hands
so good for her however in a choking
patient emergency tracheotomy may not
necessarily help okay if the food
particle is stuck further down than
where you would put the hole in the neck
however she did do her research
cricothyroid membrane is exactly where
you want to go you probably could have
just pulled the piece of pancake out of
his throat now if you want to see it
done right check out this clip from
house here we have a nice long midline
incision so you don't ding either the
carotid or the jugulars you have a quick
dissection right down to the trachea and
an insertion of the tracheotomy to
perfect very well done good cool
self-rescue Casino Royale I'm going to
pass out in a few seconds and you need
to keep your heart going push the red
button now bond
this scene has a lot of problems you're
welcome for a heart rhythm tune require
different relation it needs to be what's
called a non perfusing rhythm meaning
patient would therefore most likely be
unconscious there's really never a
situation where a patient would be awake
and able to do complex tasks like this
but also required to fibrillation don't
interrupt
if double-oh-seven is conscious and able
to have enough dexterity and mental
acuity to perform this complex task he
almost certainly is not in photography
phase and it's not like you can only be
partially in v-tach it's like being a
little bit pregnant you're either in
v-tach or you're not
thank you cliche medical terminology 10
cc's of it 500 CC's 5 cc's of that 500
CC's CC actually stands for cubic
centimeter which is the same as a
milliliter boils are dropping I tell my
medical students vitals are vital we
always talk about them we always want to
know what they are and yes we ask what
they are on the regular sinus you know
one vital that they never report on in
the movies or on TV is urine output okay
for surgeons urine output is probably
the most vital vital sign this is
actually from the Latin stem which means
immediately very commonly is would be a
great spokesperson for things music in
the operating room scrubs we need to
make this decision now Marlon it's on
you
nurse eraser Yes Doctor this is a very
accurate depiction of how the music gets
chosen for the o.r yes it is in general
the attending surgeon is the boss and
the attendant gets to pick the music I
think you saw we usually wait until the
patients asleep until we put the music
on two men but the discussion before the
operation of what we should be listening
to is a tale as old as time in the o.r
it makes you think you know better now
if you check out nip/tuck eyes without a
face by Billy Idol facial plastic
surgery do something wrong
pretty good alternatives to anesthesia
Harold & Kumar Go to White Castle
we should probably use marijuana that'll
sufficiently sedate the patient for
surgery marijuana would be a very bad
drug to anesthetize a patient with
ripping I found it really does nothing
to desensitize your awareness or your
sensation of pain another example of
where they got it wrong is in faceless
what are you doing you're crazy
patience completely wide awake for a
face transplant totally unrealistic
small bowel resection the neck we must
operate but we cannot do it to a man who
can feel pain so I think this clip is
really well done in terms of an accuracy
standpoint the description of the
operation is really well done on the
nerves in the spine between the thoracic
vertebrae 6 and 7 so as to stop the
brain from learning of the pain their
attention to historical detail is also
pretty good too in terms of having an
open our gallery people without gloves
on people without gowns and masks that's
just about accurate for the 19th century
so I know we've already discussed that
oh art galleries aren't really a thing
anymore
but back in the 19th century they
totally were and you can see that here I
know it looks scary but this is an early
prototype for a stapler that is used to
connect to portions of small bowel still
used today all right check this part out
I love this partner searchers failed in
two spots for the obstruction backed up
with pressure on them you should rethink
the neck is very accurate in terms of
representing a body part called the
mesentery which is almost never depicted
in Hollywood it's the actual connective
tissue that brings the blood supply to
and from the small bowel the Nick does
it right but so many examples where
Hollywood gets it wrong here's an
example from Hannibal where the
mesentery is just completely absent shot
mesentery never gets any love yeah I
want to tell your father all about this
timing the surgery Grey's Anatomy
you know why Cristina I'm on a clock and
you're wasting my time what's your
problem
surgeons are some of the most
competitive people on planet earth so it
really does not surprised myself that
dr. yang is timing herself doing this
procedure my personal record for
cholecystectomy is 22 minutes very nice
homemade surgical instruments dead
ringers surgeons instruments are really
extensions of their hands and certain
surgeons have very specific preferences
for the instruments that they use I've
just made brand new a lot of our
instruments are actually named after the
people who did at one point invent them
at home and bring them in to try them
out all right so these instruments are
kind of interesting they look both
futuristic and medieval at the same time
I'm afraid I'm not familiar with these
instruments doc and I can only guess
that they're used in gynecology it's a
this reaction to bleeding is a little
bit dramatic
yes patients bleed in the operating room
no people don't sort of run around and
scream the patient's bleeding stopping a
surgery at the last second house I can't
feel my lights I can't feel my legs so
I've seen a couple of patients have
panic attacks before operations before
we do any operation we go through a very
extensive checklist with the nursing
staff with the anesthesiologists it
helps us review why we're there in the
operating room what the possible risks
of the operation are and just make sure
everybody's Ducks are in a row John
we're gonna figure out what's wrong with
you first we need to know one thing
it's pretty unlikely that we would get
to the point of doing this checklist and
not really realize some kind of massive
major problem with the patient would be
having right before they get induced
under anesthesia dr. Wilson we have a
problem and check out dr. House's
clothes first of all he doesn't have a
hat on second of all he's in his street
clothes in real life that guy would have
been tackled by about six tiny
perioperative nurses far before he got
to the operating room what did you do
stealing a dead body from the hospital
from Little Miss Sunshine I have never
worked in a hospital that has patient
care rooms on the first floor hospital
windows don't even open patient is super
sick is gonna have all kinds of tubes
attached to them lines some hospitals
even have patient tracker bands that the
patient wears so you can know when the
patient for example is at the cat
scanner in the operating room you can't
just abandon the body that would set off
some alarm somewhere in the hospital the
only one is has somebody died here today
okay emergency arm amputation requiem
for a dream
[Applause]
Savva they're using is more commonly
used in autopsies to get the chest open
but not something that we would use on a
living patient no autopsies you guessed
it from Grey's Anatomy don't even tell
me you're doing what I think you don't
in real life pathologists do autopsies
these are medical doctors who are
specifically trained in this type of
procedure at this point what could it
hurt surgeons don't do them internal
medicine doctors don't do them not only
did you disregard the family's wishes
you broke the law and doing an autopsy
on a patient without that family's
informed written consent is a big big
illegal no-no huge trauma arrival
Westwick visible so even though this
patient is the president it is very
standard to have a lot of people
involved in any trauma resuscitation you
know they're gonna bill me for that
sometimes there's as many as 10 maybe 12
or 15 people in the room all there to
take care of the patient you need
medical conditions well I'm in shock
everybody has one specific job and one
specific job only you do that job and
you get out at this point most family
members are in a waiting room somewhere
we do need to all do our jobs and take
care of the patient in that moment and
it can be very distracting with a
hysterical family member in the room
mom's gonna be pretty pissed
a resident struggles in the operating
room Grey's Anatomy it's secured
directly or clinched I don't know what
to do I don't know
she's crashing in this scene we have dr.
Cristina Yang who is a resident doing a
open heart operation with her attending
in the background reading The Atlantic
Monthly
why isn't she helping so this would
never happen in real life surgeons and
residents learn to operate in a
step-by-step process that we refer to as
graded autonomy we learn the steps of an
operation and very slowly gained her
independence
teaching she's learning if a patient was
ever in trouble if the resident couldn't
get themselves out of danger in an
operating room an attending would always
step in and help
yeah he's killing her patient Altman's
reading The Atlantic Monthly totally
unrealistic surgeons don't read it like
monthly waste of time right they read
the New Yorker a surgeon removes a live
bomb Grey's Anatomy
no longer inside of me threatening the
life it belongs to surgery to remove
unexploded ordnance is a real thing the
Army has published guidelines on how to
do it safely
[Music]
arterial spray Blackhawk down
that's quite dramatic blood can spray
from an artery if it's severed in an
open wound but that specific example
personal on the loop is under quite a
bit of pressure and the human body does
not generate that amount of blood
pressure it's not possible like a
surgeon by Weird Al Yankovic
[Music]
everything depicted here in this music
video is according to my experience 100%
accurate and true just kidding it's
completely ridiculous but it's still
very funny and I love it conclusion at
the end of the day I don't expect the
directors and the actors to get every
little detail right but it's still
pretty fun to watch and by the way if
you are enjoying technique critique
subscribe to Wired step